confirmation of two jabs
and potentially that means that we can
straight off the amber list
we don't have to quarantine when is that
going to happen
well this hasn't been clinically advised
yet we're working on it
and we're working on plans to uh
to to essentially allow the vaccine to
bring back some of the freedoms that
have had to be restricted to keep people
safe i mean after all that's the whole
purpose of the vaccination program
it's why it's so important that
everybody who every adult goes out and
gets the jab and if you've had one jab
that you go and
that you go and get to because that's
where the full protection comes from
okay working on it does that mean
potentially by august so at least
people might be able to have some
semblance of a family foreign holiday
this year
well we'll get there when it's
safe to do so we want to do this right
we want to do this
carefully and properly but of course we
do want to get those freedoms back
that's the whole point of the
vaccination program so when i'm in a
position to be able to
say something more concrete than we will
do but it is absolutely something we're
working on it's something i want to see
presently costing something like 600
million pounds a day to the economy
so every day counts
well yes but the pandemic here at home
has huge costs in terms
of lives in terms of uh the economy
and so protecting this country from
uh from the uh
what can happen the variance we've seen
around the world that is a very very
important part of managing this pandemic
now
thankfully because of the vaccination
program we've been able to free up a
huge number of the restrictions here at
home
we're on track to deliver the
step four the further openings on the
19th of july
which is good um but we're also
looking to see how we can replace the
protections that
are currently there with the
restrictions with protections that come
from the vaccine
with respect to international travel as
well but it is more difficult
freeing up international travel we have
one of the tightest border control
systems in the world and we have that
because we want to protect this amazing
progress we've made at home with the
vaccination program
okay perhaps one option will be the new
app
that you want to talk to us about could
that act as a vaccine passport
well we we we can now all of us
see our vaccine status see your testing
status
on the nhs app and we've seen this
massive uptake of the nhs
app and there's there's two the one that
you use to check into venues 25 million
people have downloaded that
a smaller number six million people have
now downloaded the main nhs app
and on that you can show whether you've
had the have the jabs
and and that is a that is a it's
important because we know other
countries are going to say that they
want proof that you've been vaccinated
before you go so when travel is opened
up
we are going to make sure people have
got that um
that ability to prove it so if you go
into the app store right now okay you
can download the nhs app
it connects up with your gp records it
means that you're
more in control of your health data
which is uh which is important and one
of the big learnings from the pandemic
one of the things that we're
strengthening with the data strategy
we're setting out today
but it will also mean that you can see
your vaccination status
and see your any tests you've done
recently
to be able to um to help prove that you
haven't got the coronavirus so it's all
part of using modern technology to help
to manage this pandemic as well as
possible
okay yep i do that and i can see that
i've had both vaccines i've had that
app for a long time i'm seeing that as a
vaccine passport for me me to be able to
prove to other nations if i travel
overseas that i am
um i've had both my jobs and i'm 100
invincible
um talk to me about um dido harding if
you would she wants to run the national
health service
um and i believe uh that you are keen on
her
doing that um just looking at a track
record it's not great though is it that
track and trace not fantastic as my
viewers will know
her roles at talk talk and woolworths
weren't
ringing endorsements for her career why
do you think she would be a good leader
of the nhs
well i'm absolutely not going to get
into any individuals who put their name
forward we have an open competition
for who is going to be the next chief
executive of the nhs it's an incredibly
important job running
you know one of the most important
institutions in the country
probably the most loved and um so we've
we're looking broadly and we've invited
applications from across the board
for who can do that job it's a tough job
and um
simon stevens has done it very well over
the past eight years
but we need to make sure that the nhs
has the right leader
and we need to make sure that the nhs
looks forward and
you know the data strategy for instance
we're publishing today from the nhs
is all about how we can harness modern
technology
to make sure the care you receive is
better because
you know anybody who's used the nhs will
have had the experience of going in and
having to give their information
over and over again um and make sure
that we can
organize the nhs as well as possible
using modern technology so yeah the nhs
is thinking about
look forward my questions about dido
harding why is she a good candidate
well as i said we'll look at all of the
candidates who put their names
forward and i haven't seen the uh
the shortlist that's the whole process
is being run by the
nhs board and we do it we're being
very uh thorough and we've invited
applications from right across the world
okay okay talk to me uh about um social
care
uh we heard from your predecessor jeremy
hunt in the daily mail yesterday he says
it's a do or die
moment really and we heard that from the
prime minister two years ago
two years ago on the doorstep of number
10. you had a meeting planned
with the prime minister and the
chancellor to talk about the social care
crisis why has it been postponed
well the prime minister has been
absolutely clear
that we're going to publish the plan
for the future of social care this year
our commitment
is there in the manifesto to deliver on
social care
in this parliament and we deliver on our
commitments right we were elected to get
brexit done and we delivered on that
we said we'd protect the nhs through the
pandemic and we've delivered
on that we're currently delivering
millions and millions and millions of
vaccines uh
every week and we've committed to making
sure every adult can get a job we've
delivered on that so we will deliver on
social care
in terms of the ins and outs of the in
terms of the ins and outs of
the you know the internal processes of
course i'm not going to get into that
but what your viewers
can rest assured is that we will deliver
the plan for the reform of social care
that as you said in the question is long
overdue
okay we only have a limited amount of
time my question is why was the meeting
postponed
well what i'm telling you okay is i'm
absolutely not going to get into
uh diary management issues what i'm
going to tell you about is this
schedule given how important it is
when's it been rescheduled for
well you wouldn't it could possibly
expect me to
answer questions about private meetings
and i'm
well i'm not going to but what i am
going to do is deliver the reform of
social care that people want to see
naturally we have to delay this sorry
why not you said it's long overdue why
are you not telling us
when the meetings are going to be uh
when you're going to discuss with the
prime minister
and the chancellor of the exchequer when
something that was promised
two years ago a meeting has been
postponed you can't tell us when it's
been rescheduled for
meantime something like i think i'm
right in saying 18
000 pensioners a week of finding
themselves in a position where they're
being moved
from hospital to social care and they
don't know whether they're going to lose
their houses
because they the prime minister's not
delivered on his pro on his promise
of dealing with social care
well i don't know where to start with
the total rubbish in that question okay
firstly um i i'm absolutely not going to
get into
uh diary management i talk to the prime
minister every single day
and we're working very closely together
on the delivery of this
policy the but the second thing is
we absolutely were working on the plan
before the pandemic struck
but you'll understand and your viewers
will undoubtedly understand that when
the pandemic struck it was all hands on
deck
to to tap to you know to protect lives
and to
to get us out of this as fast as
possible and the vaccine is doing that
um and the prime minister has uh
committed
to delivering this plan before the end
of the year and we're going to do that
um hopefully this isn't as rubbish a
question then is the money there have
you
managed to have that conversation with
the chancellor
well of course the the question in terms
of social care
is both in terms of how we can best
make sure that people get the care that
they need in the setting they need
whether that's in their own home with
care coming into their own home
or of course in a care home
or and in terms of how that's paid for
and who pays for it there are many
injustices in the current system that we
want to
tackle and that's one of the reasons
this is such a
complex piece of work but it's also one
of the reasons it's such an important
piece of work
and we're absolutely determined to
deliver on it and we're going to deliver
on it
okay let's let's try this one um the
royal yacht set to cost 200 million
pounds that should we have that or
should we have
that money to pay for 8 000 extra nurses
for a year
yeah well i'm obviously not the minister
responsible for the royal yacht but what
i could tell you is i think it's a
brilliant idea
and it's a brilliant idea because it's
how we can help to sell
britain abroad and you only need to do a
small
encourage a small amount of trade in
order to pay for
a yacht like this over and over again
and by taking the yacht
essentially displaying britain in
countries around the world in harbors
around the world
from you know in new york to singapore
you can you can sell what is great about
this country and great to invest in this
country
and we've got so much to sell
you know the middle part of the 21st
century is a fantastic time
for this country if we get this right
and i think that making the investment
to be able to go and sell britain around
the world
is money well spent and i think it will
repay itself
over and over and over again so although
it's not my area
um you can tell that i'm quite i'm an
enthusiast for this
and i think that it's long overdue and
i'm absolutely
thrilled that that we're making progress
on delivering it because i think it'll
be great value for money in the narrow
sense but it's also very very important
that we sell out or sell britain around
the world
okay okay uh interestingly her majesty
is not a fan
uh so why don't you just call it a yacht
well i i i i i don't think you know and
um and i certainly don't uh know uh
of those of those opinions but what i do
know
is that this country has a huge amount
of
opportunity we've got to get through
this pandemic and get out of it of
course and we've got to build back and
learn the lessons from it
but in terms of trading with the whole
world with all the trade deals that
we're striking at the moment
we've got a huge amount of opportunity
and we've got to make the most of it
okay i know you've got to go let me ask
you very quickly before you do um the
italian prime minister wants to nab
the euro 2020 finals away from us
because he says that we've got too many
cases
of covid here in the uk what would you
say in response to him
uh well i i think these euros are going
uh very well the final set to be at
wembley
and i was at wembley on friday night it
was great to hear the
the noise of the crowds again and this
is obviously something that
uh that oliver dowden the culture
secretary
is working closely with uefa on but i
think we've got a
we've got a great setup and uh it's an
and i i hope that either england or
scotland or wales
or potentially two are in the final that
would be absolutely brilliant it's great
to see
uh wales through it's great to see last
night england are through
and um and maybe i hope scotland can get
through as well that would be uh that
would be brilliant if all three got to
the
last 16 that would be an amazing
performance for for the home nations
a diplomat and a politician to the end
it's always good to talk to you mr
hancock thank you for joining us this
morning